Obsessive compulsive disorder,
so chronic handwashing for example,
is this is as an anxiety disorder,
but there is an anxiety component to it,
but I don't believe that that's an
accurate classification.
I think that obsessive compulsive
disorder is actually a disorder of
disgust because all of the behaviors,
including hyper grooming people
sometimes have trichotillomania.
They'll pull out the hairs on their
body.
The grooming behaviors and that sort of
thing seemed to be more associated with
the operation of the disgust system and
almost everything about obsessive
compulsive disorder has a disgust basis.
And so one of the things that people who
are who have ocd obsessive about is that
I've got a client once who was this poor
woman.
By the time her ocd was done with her.
She built the equivalent of an airlock
on her house.
Like not technically proficient or
anything like that.
And her husband and her children had to
go through an elaborate decontamination
process before they were allowed to step
foot in the house.
And one of the things she was very
concerned about was that she would go
out to a supermarket and touch a piece
of fruit.
And,
and become contaminated and then come
home and touch her children and then
they would become contaminated and so
while she ended up in the hospital and
she was divorced and I just did it in
her life,
you know,
and so then people who have obsessive
compulsive disorder,
you know,
they'll,
they'll wash their hands until the soap
is gone,
like a whole bar of soap.
Right.
And you can often tell who they are
because their hands are shiny from
Washington much and they'll shower,
it can't get out of the shower,
they'll shower until the hot water is
completely gone and you know,
so the self cleaning mechanism so to
speak,
have gone seriously astray and the way
you treat them as by exposing them to
things that are disgusting and
contaminating.
I had a client with ocd once,
he was quite the character and I.
One of the things I had him do was we
would look for things on the Internet,
pictures of things that really disgusted
him.
It's not that much fun by the way,
treating someone who has ocd because I'm
rather disgust sensitive.
And so that was also rather hard on me,
so anyways,
we would look for things on the Internet
that,
that he really didn't like.
And then I'd print them out and have him
put him on his fridge,
which he did not like at all.
And he would,
he would,
he had a bunch of other problems and we
got along quite well.
But for a long time I treated him for
about three years.
He would phone me like three or four
times a day because he had obsessive
compulsive disorder and just swear at me
like mad,
you know,
just swear it,
it,
get these messages.
He'd,
he,
he phoned me and he was just so mad at
me because I'd have to put these things
on his fridge,
you know?
And so he'd curse and swear and yell at
me.
And then two minutes later he would
phone and apologize and say he was
really sorry and helped.
I would continue to see them.
And God,
that just went.
I just went on forever.
But I felt sorry for the poor guy.
You know,
he eventually ended up getting a puppy.
You agreeable people.
Oh,
puppy God,
God,
unbelievable.
A.
Yeah.
Anyways,
that was good for him because he had to
go around and clean up after the PA,
PA,
but that had poor puppy.
It was quite dominant and had all the
things that happened to that poor guy so
the puppy would dominate him,
so he'd take it outside to take it for a
walk and he wasn't a very skilled person
in many,
many ways.
He had a very large number of severe
impediments and so,
but he really liked this pop.
He didn't have any friends or anything
like that and he was supported by his
aged mother and God.
It was just a catastrophe and he'd go
outside and try to walk the puppy and
the puppy would just sit down,
right,
because it was doing dominant stuff and
he didn't know how to overcome it and
then these crazy people from across the
way who styled themselves as animal
rights activists started to harass me
and they phoned up his mother and told
them that if they,
if,
if she didn't take the dog away from
that retard,
they were going to come over and do
terrible things to him and then he got
harassed on the street and then he went
to a park with his dog and they came up
to him and pushed him on the card and
swiped his dog and ran off to the,
to the SPCA and dumped it there and he
had to move away from his apartment and
God,
it was just,
it was just an absolute catastrophe.
They had plenty of sympathy for that
damn dog,
but no sympathy whatsoever for the guy,
you know.
It was really,
it was really something.
Anyways,
that story ended happily.
Weirdly enough.
He got a.
He got a job with a woman who used to be
a psychiatric nurse who was training
dogs and she gave him a little job
setting up the dog training thing and
then he got to learn to train his dog.
He lost like he was a thin guy to begin
with.
He lost like 30 pounds trying to learn
how to take care of this puppy.
It was just.
I thought he was gonna die,
but there is no way he was going to give
up that dog.
And so anyways,
OCD,
it's quite the bloody catastrophe.
So.
And it's a good thing for someone who
has ocd to have a dog,
right?
Because dogs are messy and so there's
all sorts of things that are messy about
them,
but you have to kind of live with the
mess.
Like you have to live with the mass.
If you're going to have a child or if
you're going to have a partner of any
sort,
you know,
you,
you can't let the orderliness part of
you get the upper hand so terribly that
it's impossible for you to lift.